und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend zwei verlängerungs nächte reihum
übermüdete genervte gesichter und am
ende bekam man mit ach und krach nur
einen minimalkompromiss hin
die weltklimakonferenz in madrid wird
als enttäuschung in die geschichte der
klimakonferenzen eingehen
das ist immerhin kein rückschritt gab
und das bis heute als erfolg geltende
pariser abkommen von 2015 nicht auch
noch nachträglich verbessert wurde wird
klimaschutz kaum trösten denn der
umsetzung des abkommens ist man in
madrid keinen schritt weitergekommen
ulrike röttger berichtet einer der
eindringlichsten botschaften zum
un-klimagipfel kam aus dem weltall per
live interview von luca pagano dem
kommandeur der internationalen
raumstation
unser planet ist unglaublich schön und
worte können diese schönheit gar nicht
beschreiben
gleichzeitig aber ist unser planet
fragil und es macht angst und ist sehr
traurig die auswirkungen des
klimawandels zu sehen und mich bringt es
dazu etwas dagegen zu tun
passend dazu das offizielle motto der
konferenz zeit zu handeln
heute nun ging der gipfel zu ende nach
13 verhandlungstagen
es ist ganz klar die beschlüsse die wir
heute gefasst haben reichen nicht aus
deshalb sind wir auch nicht zufrieden
damit werden wir der dringlichkeit der
klimakrise nicht gerecht
zu diesem zeitpunkt waren viele
delegierte schon abgereist und die
gastgeberin selbst erschöpft
ich bin aus glaubt wirklich ausgelaugt
und das ergebnis der konferenz eine
bittere enttäuschung sagen viele
[Musik]
es war ein ungleichgewicht hier ich
verstehe nicht warum die delegierten so
angst haben den ball so nah russ dieser
welt entgegen zu treten
die den amazonas zerstören oder den
trumps dieser welt die es im klima
abkommen von paris ausgestiegen sind ich
habe das gefühl dass sie interessen
dieser länder eher gehör finden
wir haben die wichtigsten fragen unter
den teppich gekehrt ärmeren ländern die
vom klimawandel besonders betroffen sind
geholfen wird oder die konkrete
klimaschutzziele erreicht werden können
wir haben den eindruck dass hier einige
länder einen kampf gegen den
multilateralismus also gegen die
zusammenarbeit von staaten führen weil
sie nicht daran glauben sondern weil sie
nur an nationale interessen glauben
geeinigt haben sich die vertreter der
konferenz auf etwas was für die
protestierenden schon lange
selbstverständlich ist nämlich die
anerkennung dass der klimawandel eine
gemeinsame sorge der menschheit sei und
die klimaschutzziele bis 2030 verschärft
werden sollen weitere maßnahmen
fehlanzeige
so wurde die regelung der sogenannten
klimaschutz gutschriften verschoben die
verschmutzer dazu bringen soll in
umweltfreundliche technologien zu
investieren
auch kein ergebnis gab es beim
sogenannten warschau mechanismus der
armen ländern helfen soll die besonders
vom klimawandel betroffen sind
angesichts solcher bilder scheint die
dringlichkeit zu handeln größer zu sein
als je
der nächste gipfel findet im november
2020 im schottischen glasgow statt wenig
zeit um die entscheidenden weichen zu
stellen zur rettung unseres planeten
erde die konflikte die sich da auf
internationaler bühne beobachten lassen
gibt es aber auch innerhalb jedes landes
auch bei uns und da geht es nicht um
klimawandel leugner die
wissenschaftliche fakten nicht wahr
haben wollen sondern um die frage welche
folgen umweltpolitische entscheidungen
für einzelne branchen oder auch einzelne
haushalte haben
der aufzug von mehreren tausend wütende
landwirte mit ihren traktoren in berlin
beispielsweise gibt eine ahnung davon
welches gesellschaftliches konnte
gesellschaftliche konflikt potenzial
hier liegt risse können aber auch quer
durch familien gehen etwa wenn der sohn
zu frei der future geht während der
vater sich sorgen um seinen arbeitsplatz
in der automobilindustrie macht eva
schiller zeigt das am beispiel einer
familie aus baden württemberg
jonathan ist 17 klima aktivist
organisiert die proteste in stuttgart
sein vater gehört zur führungsriege
eines großen deutschen autokonzerns ist
stolz auf den verkaufsrekord im letzten
monat
auch wenn das auch ein erfolg ist er
sich bei mir im kelp beutel für unter
umständen wieder bemerkbar macht
jonathan will veränderung jetzt sofort
keine kompromisse mit einem klima
päckchen ab
was keine einzige wirkungsvolle maßnahme
hinsicht hat anfangs wirklich was in
berlin da die ganze zeit überhaupt
machen
sein vater spürt schon was die
politischen entscheidungen die abkehr
vom diesel bedeutet für die
arbeitsplätze in der automobilindustrie
es ist ein schock und ich weiß was es
bedeutet von freunden verwandten
verwandten sogar schon mal einen bruder
wende wenn der arbeitsplatz droht
verloren zu gehen
es geht ein riss durch baden württemberg
in den letzten jahren zugpferd der
deutschen wirtschaft jetzt hagelt es
hiobsbotschaften
daimler baut 6600 stellenabbaus 2600
allein in 2009 10 hat die deutsche
autoindustrie den abbau von 50.000 jobs
angekündigt grün um jeden preis diese
frage spaltet das land und familien hast
du das gefühl dass du durch einen arbeit
in auch die industrie meiner zukunft was
gutes tust ja die habe ich es ist für
mich die nummer eins dass wir
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich sind um das
geld zu das geld zu verdienen
die wir morgen in die nachhaltigkeit in
die modernste umwelttechnologien
investieren können
jonathan findet die konzerne haben die
abkehr vom verbrenner verschlafen wenn
die grünen wiederum dann fordern dass
man bis 2030 oder ab 2030 den verbrenner
verbietet dann gibt's ja schon lauter
aufschrei in der automobilbranche und
dann wird sich dagegen gewehrt
das kann ich nicht bestätigen weil ich
für äußerst ist eine ganz klare aussage
geht das bis 2039 all dieses beendet ist
ja noch mal neun jahre unterschied neun
jahre zeit das sind im kampf gegen die
klimakrise einiges
die mobilitäts wende braucht zeit findet
jonathans vater es kann nicht schnell
genug gehen entgegnet jonathan mein
vater wünsche mir dass er eben auch
seiner jobsuche sich auch in anderen
berechnungen schon baden württembergs
wohlstand steht auf dem spiel die einen
meinen es braucht einschnitte und mut um
das klima zu retten die anderen zittern
um ihre zukunft wie man ökologie und
ökonomie miteinander verbinden kann
damit beschäftigt sich professor ottmar
edenhofer chefökonom und direktor des
potsdam instituts für
klimafolgenforschung und an
professorinnen hofer guten abend das
ökologische notwendigkeiten und
ökonomische interessen aufeinander
stoßen das ist ja sozusagen ihr
fachgebiet
haben sie verständnis dafür dass
menschen sich einfach auch sorgen ihre
arbeitsplätze machen zum beispiel jetzt
in der automobilbranche
natürlich habe ich verständnis dafür
dass sich menschen sorgen machen wenn es
darum geht arbeitsplätze zu erhalten
oder wenn sie befürchten dass
arbeitsplätze verloren gehen
nur ist es ja nicht so dass wir jetzt
einfach klimaschutz machen um den
menschen das leben schwer zu machen
sondern klimaschutz heißt dass wir
gefährlichen klimawandel vermeiden und
würden wir so weitermachen wie bisher
dann wäre der wohlstand des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts bedroht
werden klimawandel führt dazu dass wir
wohlstand vernichten also klimapolitik
gut gemachte klimapolitik hilft den
wohlstand des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts zu sichern
es ist nicht ein problem das die kosten
des klimawandels sehr viel später voll
spürbar während während die kosten von
klimaschutz schon jetzt sofort spürbar
sind
ja das ist sicher ein problem dass es da
ein zeitproblem gibt aber es ist auch so
wenn wir jetzt noch lange warten mit der
klimapolitik oder mit dem klimaschutz
dann wird es immer teurer
um dann tatsächlich die selbst gesetzten
klimaziele zu erreichen
es bleibt ein generationenkonflikt aber
ich glaube dass es ein gutes
kaufmännisches verständnis dass man
nicht von der substanz lebt und was wir
im augenblick machen ist dass wir von
der substanz leben weil wir eben die
kosten des ungebremsten klimawandels wie
man so schön sagt nicht einpreisen
und das ist eigentlich kein guter
ratgeber für die wirtschaftspolitik
ein problem ist auch ein
akzeptanzproblem das dann eben auch
immer eine relativ große anzahl von
menschen geben wird die finden dass sie
ein ungerecht hohen anteil am
klimaschutz haben also zum beispiel wir
wollen keine atomkraftwerke aber man
will auch nicht die stromtrasse oder das
windrad direkt vor der eigenen haustür
haben oder wenn wir an die landwirte
denken die jetzt in berlin
demonstrierten wie kann man so etwas
auflösen
ja das ist natürlich in der tat eine
wichtige frage wie können die kosten die
belastungen des klimaschutzes gerecht
verteilt werden und das geht natürlich
denn wenn man zum beispiel co2 preise
erhebt dann erhält generiert man
einnahmen um mit diesen einnahmen kann
man diejenigen entlasten die über
ansonsten überproportional von einer
klimapolitik belastet werden das haben
wir oft durchgerechnet es ist nur schade
dass sich die politik den bislang
verweigert und eben keine gerechten und
keine ambitionierten
kompensationsmaßnahmen durchführt wenn
man das machen würde dann könnte man
diejenigen tatsächlich entlasten die
jetzt die lasten überproportional
schultern müssen
auf internationaler ebene stellt sich im
grunde das gleiche problem haben sie
insofern erwartet dass das jetzt in
madrid mit zu einem ja kleinen
minimalkompromiss ausgehen würde da
hatten sie da größere hoffnungen vorfeld
also man muss ja der gerechtigkeit
halber sagen dass madrid immer so eine
art technische veranstaltung war da ging
es um buchhaltungsregeln da geht es
darum dass man versucht keine
doppelungen aufkommen zu lassen wenn es
um den emissionshandel geht also es war
immer sehr technisch und es war
eigentlich auch nicht auf der
tagesordnung dass jetzt der große
transferzahlungen an andere länder
geleistet werden aber es ist ja klar wer
internationalen klimaschutz will der
muss natürlich für einen ausgleich
sorgen muss diejenigen unterstützen die
vom klimawandel besonders betroffen sind
oder die besonders hohe kosten schultern
müssen und dafür gibt es ja auch eine
institution der sogenannte green climate
fand den müsste man sehr viel stärker
ausstatten dann wenn wir das nicht
machen dann dürfen wir uns nicht wundern
dass viele länder bei der klimapolitik
nicht mitmachen wollen
eines der instrumente dass sie ja auch
empfehlen sind die zertifikate die es ja
auch bereits gibt aber dagegen erhebt
sich auch kritik gerade auch von
klimaschützern die sagen dass es
eigentlich instrument mit dem kann zum
104 betrogen werden und zum anderen kann
man sich dann eigentlich freikaufen von
klimaschutzaktivitäten ja das erste
argument ist richtig wenn zb deutschland
einen solarpark in brasilien baut dann
stellt sich die frage wie viele
emissionen werden damit vermieden und
die zweite frage die sich stellt geben
können denn die emissionsminderung
angerechnet werden und in madrid wollte
brasilien das eben beiden ländern die
emissionsminderungen angerechnet werden
was natürlich unsinnig ist denn am ende
wird das dazu führen dass die emissionen
steigen das kann es ja nicht sein aber
man muss eben solche schlupflöcher
stopfen und das gute an madrid
zumindestens ist dass man sich nicht
darauf eingelassen hat diese
schlupflöcher überhaupt zuzulassen und
so fern war es gut
diese vereinbarungen zu vertagen das
zweite argument man kann sich mit dem
emissionshandel freikaufen das ist
eigentlich kein gutes argument denn am
ende des tages kann sich niemand
freikaufen es kann nämlich nur derjenige
zertifikate verkaufen
der vorher emissionsminderungen
durchgeführt hat sagt der klimaökonom
und fachmann professor ordner edenhofer
vom potsdam institut für klimaforschung
vielen dank ich danke ihnen das gespräch
haben wir vor einer stunde geführt auf
heute de finden sie weitere hintergründe
zum thema klima und den
weltklimakonferenz und jetzt geht's erst
mal mit den nachrichten weiter und mit
heinz wolf bundesarbeitsminister heil
will das gesetz zur grundrente gleich zu
beginn des neuen jahres auf den weg
bringen
es soll im januar im kabinett
beschlossen und ins parlament
eingebracht werden wie heil der bild am
sonntag sagte
die grundrechte sei ein wichtiger
beitrag für die bekämpfung von
altersarmut besonders frauen
profitierten davon so der minister
cdu-chefin kramp karrenbauer hatte
anfang dezember den start des
gesetzgebungsverfahrens zur grundrente
vom verbleib der spd in der großen
koalition abhängig gemacht
wieder haben erdbeben den süden der
philippinen erschüttert und dabei
erreichten die schwersten erdstöße eine
stärke von 6,8
mindestens vier menschen kamen ums leben
einige sollen verschüttet oder verletzt
sein
die philippinen liegen auf einem
vulkangürtel und seit monaten gibt es
dort immer wieder heftige beben seit
wochen protestieren tausende menschen im
libanon gegen die regierung der sie
misswirtschaft und korruption vorwerfen
trotz häufiger polizeigewalt sind sie
auch jetzt wieder auf den straßen der
hauptstadt beirut ihre proteste heute
abend richten sich gegen ex
regierungschef hariri
er war unter dem druck der proteste ende
oktober zurückgetreten wird aber wieder
als premier gehandelt
bei den protesten gestern waren mehr als
100 demonstranten verletzt worden
wie immer zum winterfahrplan gelten neue
bahn preise in einigen bereichen im
nahverkehr steigen sie um 1,7 prozent
ansonsten sinken sie
so fällt der super sparpreis auf 17 eur
90 auf tickets im fernverkehr fällt die
mehrwertsteuer zum jahreswechsel von 19
auf sieben prozent allerdings nur wenn
sich bundestag und bundesrat bis
weihnachten auf die im klima paket
enthaltene maßnahme einigen außerdem
gibt es neue verbindungen gerade im
osten sowie auf einigen strecken mehr
züge als in kandel ein flüchtling seine
15 jährige ex freundin tötete
beschäftigte dass die ganze republik die
kleinstadt kandel wurde zu einem
politischen symbol und wenige monate
später wurde in berlin eine 14 jährige
von einem mitschüler ermordet das wurde
kein politikum der berliner täter hieß
auch nicht abtun sondern trägt einen
deutschen namen anderes beispiel die
messerattacke auf einen polizisten am
münchner hauptbahnhof anfang der woche
als eine afd politikerin von der
münchner polizei per twitter wissen
wollte welche vornamen der täter hat
wurde sie von der twitter redaktion der
polizei sehr nachdrücklich darauf
hingewiesen dass sie da auf einer
falschen fährte sein
der täter ist deutsche ohne
migrationshintergrund in vielen medien
berichten über den fall spielt die
herkunft des täters keine rolle
ganz anders bei dem tod eines
feuerwehrmanns wenige tage zuvor in
augsburg das wirft fragen auf wie medien
bei kriminalfällen mit der herkunft von
tätern umgehen und zu welchem
wahrnehmungs verzerrungen das führen
kann
damit hat sich eine neue studie befasst
über die florian leu hand berichtet ein
spielzeug feuerwehrauto haben sie
hingestellt für den feuerwehrmann der
hier vor über einer woche erschlagen
wurde
eine schreckliche bereit es ist ein satz
am ende an der pressekonferenz der aus
diesem verbrechen eine bundesweite
geschichte macht auch im zdf wir haben
bei fünf der täter auch andere zum teil
auch andere nämlich türkische
staatsangehörigkeit und der 1
der ist auch libanesische
staatsangehörige die herkunft der
mutmaßlichen täter veröffentlicht von
der augsburger polizei sofort
aufgegriffen von rechts wie hier von afg
fraktionschefin weide ein neuerliches
opfer von migranten gewalt aber spielt
die herkunft hier wirklich eine
entscheidende rolle
in einer stadt in der die polizei keine
erhöhte gewalt von migranten feststellen
kann ist das verbrechen den augsburg
etwa wegen der herkunft der täter
wichtiger als zum beispiel die tat eines
deutschen der zwei tage später in
lörrach eine frau ersticht
was bundesweit kaum bemerkt wird der
serbe soll für den täter ein 24 jähriger
afghane junge albanische was nicht
einbreche der irakische flüchtlinge ali
b gestand tatsächlich wird die herkunft
von tatverdächtigen immer öfter genannt
aber fast ausschließlich wenn es sich
nicht um deutsche handelt 2014 in 4,8
prozent der tv beitrag über gewalttaten
2009 10 schon in 31 prozent und sogar in
44 der zeitungsartikel studienautor
thomas estermann für den anstieg zurück
auf die silvesternacht von köln 2015 als
viele medien auch das zdf erst nach
tagen ausführlich über die gewalttaten
junger meist nordafrikanischer männer
berichtet hatten
nach der können silvesternacht hatten
viele vorwürfe erhoben gegenüber den
medien lügen presse lücken presse das
sind vorwürfe die schmerzen und viele
haben dann versucht dagegen zu halten
und haben eben ganz verstärkt herkunft
eben von tatverdächtigen genannt aber
sie haben dabei übersehen dass es eben
auch viele deutsche tatverdächtige
captain die bleiben fast komplett
ausgeblendet
eine zwickmühle in der polizei und
medien stecken nennen sie die herkunft
nicht kommen wie auch nach der ersten
polizeimeldungen in augsburg die
vorwürfe man muss doch wissen nach dem
mann fahndet der nordrhein westfälische
innenminister reue will seine polizei
daher verpflichten die herkunft von
tatverdächtigen immer zu nennen auch bei
deutschen ich habe einfach große sorgen
dass wir wenn wir da nicht handeln
weiter zulassen dass insbesondere im
rechtsextremistischen bereich im netz
die hetzer unterwegs sind die leute
unterwegs sind und gerüchte in die welt
setzen nach dem motto die polizei der
stadt verschweigt dass weil in
wirklichkeit nur verschweigen will das
als ausländer sind das klingt zwar gut
meint fördert amann vom verein neuer
deutscher medienmacher der sich für
vielfalt einsetzt doch die herkunft zu
erwähnen verstärke bloß vorurteile
denn wenn sie die herkunft nennen dann
entsteht der eindruck dass sein
zusammenhang bestünde
und das wiederum führt zu
diskriminierungen zu stigmatisierung und
wir haben eigentlich als journalistinnen
den auftrag nicht zu stigmatisieren und
nicht zu diskriminierung beizutragen
die tat von augsburg bleibt kaum zu
fassen und die frage ob dabei die
herkunft der tatverdächtigen eine rolle
spielt mindestens umstritten
und jetzt nochmal heinz mit meldungen
vom sport in der fußball bundesliga gibt
es einen wechsel an der tabellenspitze
ganz oben steht nach dem 15 spieltag rb
leipzig denn der vfl wolfsburg hat zwei
zu 1 gegen borussia mönchengladbach
gewonnen und zwar das klappt auch nicht
geschafft die tabellenführung zu
verteidigen
im zweiten sonntagsspiel hat schalke 1 0
gegen eintracht frankfurt gewonnen
die niederlande sind zum ersten mal
frauen handball weltmeister durch eine
30 29-sieg gegen spanien im finale der
wm in japan und die niederlande die
niederländer rennen und haben damit auch
die direkte qualifikation für die
olympischen spiele im kommenden jahr
geschafft wie das deutsche team als
wm-achte verpasst hat die deutsche
biathlon-staffel der männer hat in
hochfilzen den sieg knapp verpasst den
holte sich norwegen im spannenden
schlussspurt
so sieht jemand aus der sich auf der
schlussrunde vollkommen verausgabt hat
benedikt doll deutschlands schlussläufer
beim letzten schießen zunächst klar im
vorteil doch dann zeigt der
sprintweltmeister von 2017 nerven muss
zweimal nachladen
er geht zwar als erster zurück auf die
schlussrunde doch der norweger johannes
teenies bekommt man er hat einfach die
fähigkeit zu sagen naja ich laufe jetzt
einfach schneller
dass die lücke zu geht auf der
zielgeraden die attacke soll muss sich
geschlagen geben hauchten der vorsprung
des norwegers nur zwei sekunden
für die deutschen männer ist dieser
zweite platz ein versöhnlicher abschluss
hier in hochfilzen auf rang drei die
staffel aus frankreich gastgeber der
nächsten weltcup woche
in fünf monaten am 16 mai eröffnen
wieder die passionsspiele in
oberammergau proben haben bereits
begonnen und damit ist praktisch ganz
oberammergau beschäftigt alle zehn jahre
führt ja die 5000 einwohner gemeinde das
drama um die leiden jesu auf mit
laienschauspielern aus dem ort nicht
immer bei deren auswahl unumstritten als
1990 erstmals ein evangelischer
oberammergauer die hauptrolle übernahm
sorgte das für aufregung
und auch diesmal gibt es einige denen
die besetzung nicht passt weil ein
muslimischer oberammergauer dem judas
spielt patricia schäfer berichtet es ist
das größte was oberammergau zu bieten
hat die passionsspiele alle zehn jahre
seit 1634 bringen die dorfbewohner die
passion christi auf die bühne
von einer hauptrolle bei dem
massenspektakel träumen fast alle im
dorf der neue jesus ist rox rückl 24 und
katholisch erzogen
cengiz gerührt 19 jahre alt und muslim
spielt den judas
das hat für aufsehen gesorgt es gibt von
mir selber persönlich aus auch überhaupt
keine probleme oder so also ohne
irgendwie dass mir unangenehm ist oder
dass ich jetzt mich fragt es ist in
ordnung ob ich jetzt als muslim mit wer
solche fragen stelle ich mir gar nicht
also ich bin hier darum dass janis
ausgerechnet den judas spielt lässt erst
recht aufhorchen aber nur wenn man nicht
aus oberammergau kommt hier gilt judas
nämlich nicht unbedingt als negative
figur sind um dem verräter ruf aber
eigentlich auch die interessanteste
rolle also wenn sie hoch interessante
rolle also judas es bei uns im dorf so
oder so schon seit ich glaube seitdem
die passionsspiele inszeniert werden
schon einer der begehrtesten rollen im
mai ist premiere
deshalb trifft man hier auffallend viele
bärtige die proben beginnen und seit
monaten lassen die oberammergauer haare
und bärte sprießen
spielleiter christian stückl inszeniert
die passionsspiele schon zum vierten mal
nah am bibeltext aber immer wieder
anders
uns ist des passionsspiels seit 1900
wirtschaftsfaktor für die gemeinde
geworden und das hat dazu geführt dass
es eher stagniert ist dass man so viel
angst hatte vor veränderung angst dass
das publikum kann vielleicht ausbleiben
würde ich bin mit 24 zum passionsspiel
leiter gewählt worden und bei erster
satz war ich wir werden es verändert
immer wieder neu anfangen immer wieder
die geschichten erzählen und es gab in
den letzten 30 jahren viele
veränderungen erst durften auch
evangelische oberammergauer mitspielen
dann verheiratete frauen vor 20 jahren
gab es kleine rollen für die ersten
türkischstämmigen dorfbewohner und jetzt
eben eine hauptrolle
auch nach dem kirchgang ist das ein
thema es ist ein gutes gefühl
es soll der christliche spiel sein und
bleiben so ein völkergemisch damals in
israel und das wird hier wieder
abgebildet und ob die judas jetzt
muslimisches oder nicht das bild eine
nachrangige rolle
grundsätzlich gilt jeder der hier
geboren ist oder seit mindestens 20
jahren in oberammergau wohnt hat das
spielrecht in welcher rolle entscheidet
der spielleiter cengiz und rochus wollen
vor allem eines ihrem tragenden rollen
gerecht werden die religion soll da
keine grenze darstellen
das ist egal ob du jetzt christ best of
duty ist oder ob du moslem ist es ist
kommt nur darauf an ob die theater
spielen kannst oder nicht an die glaubt
das ist auch ein teil der message von
jesus dass die langsam kämen wir sind
und das tun die oberammergauer sie
proben und sie spielen zusammen und
vergessen dabei das kreuz mit dem
kulturellen trennlinien und jetzt noch
wie jeden sonntag der blick auf die
nächste woche kamera vier jahren hat
drei ereignisse ausgewählt über die auch
das heute journal berichten wird
[Musik]
wo gibt es fachkräfte und wie können sie
schneller nach deutschland kommen
darüber diskutieren morgen
spitzenvertreter im kanzleramt
dabei soll auch das im juni beschlossene
fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetz auf den
prüfstand
es soll qualifizierten arbeitnehmern aus
nicht eu staaten den weg nach
deutschland ebnen
bisher gibt es lange wartezeiten für
visa beethoven ab morgen wird er ein
jahr lang gefeiert
im jubiläumsjahr zu seinem 250
geburtstag zeigt die bundeskunsthalle
sein lebenswerk
hier eine skizze zur ode an die freude
in seinem renovierten geburtshaus in
bonn findet man seinen flügel und seine
ohrmuschel mit der er zeitlebens gegen
seine schwerhörigkeit ankämpfte
[Musik]
am donnerstag stellte sich den fragen
von internationalen journalisten
kremlchef wladimir putin in seiner
pressekonferenz zum jahresabschluss darf
man gespannt sein wie reagierte auf die
verlängerten eu sanktionen gegen
russland und wie ist seine haltung in
syrien und ukraine konflikt eine
ausblick fehlt noch aufs wetter morgen
fällt im nordwesten etwas regen
die sonne zeigt sich vor allem im süd an
den alpen gibt es für die temperatur
erreicht im norden 6 bis 10 grad im
süden 9 bis 14 grad
die kommenden tage werden abseits
einiger nebelfelder im süden durchweg
freundlich am dienstag 9 bis 16 grad
und auch wenn es danach etwas kühler
wird es bleibt für die jahreszeit viel
zu mild das war es von uns an diesem
sonntagabend mit dem sportler des jahres
jetzt festlich weiter und um 0.30 gibt
es dann die nächste heute express und
hier erwarten sie morgen claus kleber
und gundula gause
schönen abend noch auf wiedersehen
[Musik]